[موسيقى]
نحاول العثور على الأماكن التي
يتراكم فيها البلاستيك معظم
أنهار ما قبل التاريخ والذي أصبح الآن مكانًا
تجد فيه العقول الساطعة اليوم
مكانًا مناسبًا في قطاع الشركات الناشئة المزدهر في مصر من
خلال الاعتراف بأن الشركات يمكنها أن تعمل
بشكل جيد من خلال فعل
الخير.  m khadija amrahafiz أنا مؤسس مشارك في
النيل جدا ونحن هنا نقوم بتنظيف
النيل من الزجاجات البلاستيكية كيلوغرام واحد في كل
مرة لم يقم بها أحد في مصر حتى الآن
وما يلهمني حقًا هو التغيير
الذي يحدثه حل النيل للغاية
بناء ما يسمى بالجيش الأخضر من خلال
تجنيد الأشخاص الذين يعرفون
النهر أفضل الصيادين في القاهرة ،
إنه موردنا الرئيسي في مصر
حيث يعيش معظم الناس على الرغم من أن
أسلافنا
عاشوا في الماضي من النيل الذي أكلوه من
النيل الذي شربوه  من النيل نريد
إحياء هذا التراث واحتضان
جمال النيل
حتى الآن قمنا بجمع أكثر من 54 طنًا من
البلاستيك من النيل ويجمعون يوميًا
من 100 إلى 150 كجم من البلاستيك
وهو موقع مربح للجانبين  التي
نستفيد منها من تنظيف النيل ويستفيدون من نهر
أنظف
ومصدر دخل أفضل
لأن الصيادين يتقاضون رواتبهم من
ثقبهم البلاستيكي بالكيلو الذي
يتم فيه فرز البلاستيك ووزنه لإعادة
تدويره أو إعادة تدويره
في بعض الحالات  إلى
منتجات مختلفة يتم بيعها بعد ذلك ، نقوم بتجميع
الأكياس البلاستيكية المستعملة الخاصة بك وهنا نقوم
بفصل الأكياس البلاستيكية البيضاء عن
الأكياس البلاستيكية الملونة ثم نقوم
بقصها ثم نقوم بكيها
ثم نقوم بتحويلها إلى منتجات مثل
الحقائب مثل الأرائك وأغطية الكمبيوتر المحمول
لخديجة  التأثير شخصي بدرجة أكبر
، فلن يتم تنفيذ الحل
بالكامل أبدًا دون
تغيير الطريقة التي يفكر بها الناس وكيف ينظرون إلى
الأشياء الضارة مثل النفايات البلاستيكية ،
ونأمل أن نقوم بتغيير
في المستقبل للمساعدة في إنشاء مصر أفضل